I had the dream again  I saw it were you inside Benny the bull  again little Lord no it was the  three-eyed bird  might as well tank next year we've got  no chance since maester rivers went west  you know nothing Rondo when I ordered a  Gasol brother got knocked out by two  funder I don't believe it but here you  are Here I am I'll take that hotdog now  I'll tell you what we'll trade you one  of our hot dogs for one of yours give us  a go at the point guard like to have me  a little one-on-one with this one you  were talk  stalkers make me thirsty this here these  are the kings colors no one's standing  in our way now the Coons Carmelo after  surge Orden I have only loved one  players  the black mamba  you  you